Brazil has declared three days of
mourning for the football legend Pele
the Brazilian icon who won three World
COPS has passed away from cancer at 82.
Pele found Fame as a teenager with the
football club Santos and became
internationally known when he scored
twice as Brazil beat Sweden in the 1958
World Cup final he won the competition
again in 1962 and a third time in 1970
where his mesmerizing play cemented his
iconic status
for many in Brazil and around the world
he was much more than a sportsman
Sao Paulo's Albert Einstein hospital
where football legend Pele passed away
his fans gathered outside to Bid
Farewell and mourned the loss of the man
Brazilians called the king
I came to pay my respects my goodbye in
fact the king Never Dies for me he did
not die I came to pay my respects
people also came out to Urbano Caldera
Stadium home to pele's former football
club Santos
Rio's statue of Christ the Redeemer was
lit up in his honor
and tributes were laid outside Maracana
stadium
for me soccer is in mourning we had our
defeat Brazil lost the World Cup and we
have the news of the death of our King
but Life Goes On
I'm very sad but Pele was history a
legend Helen
well great also inspired athletes in
Sports
he had a great impact on athletes in
general everyone wanted to be the Pele
in their sport it became a joke
Brazil is now beginning three days of
mourning for a footballer who
transcended the game
David trihorn is the director of the
Netflix documentary Pele and met the
footballing legend many times and we
welcome him now David you knew him
personally what was he like
uh yeah I was very lucky and and
privileged I guess and honored to have
spent quite a bit of time with him
um I originally met him 15 years ago I
think on some filming work and then
again a few years later and then we did
a big film with him from Netflix
Pele was an absolute gentleman people
talk about him as a great player and a
great man and he was a great man he
would come into the room
um and in that period he was already a
little bit physically incapacitated but
he would light up a room he wanted to
get to know everyone he wanted to chat
to everyone he I think he loved being
the king he had such a warm personal tea
and a warm way about him he wanted
everyone to feel this warmth he had I
think yeah that one certainly came
through I'm sure there are lots of
nuggets to choose from but what in his
biography did you find most compelling
we looked for the because he had this
career that was just one big high uh we
were actually looking for the lows
within it and it was very very difficult
to find so I think what we found most
interesting propelling was the fact that
I think we all remember Pele now for
1970 that was the tournament that
stamped his legacy stamped his legacy
and made Brazil what it is today the
country of football
um perhaps more so than even 1958 when
he was a teenager but I think what we
didn't realize was there was this
genuine Chance wouldn't play in 1970 it
retired from the national team he got
fed up with playing for Brazil
um and they had to coax him back
um but I don't think if Pele had 1970 uh
or had not had 1970 we'd talk about him
in the same way today
without question Pele was an iconic
footballer but people say he transcended
the sport and I imagine you agree
we transcended the sport and I think we
have to remember the era he came up
through you know this was the birth of
football as big business this is the
birth of football
um
as a commercial uh entity and in many
ways Pele was the first modern Superstar
um and you've got this guy who who sort
of fell into abusively as well he had
this incredible smile he looked amazing
um he was incredibly Adept at proving
these iconic moments uh on the biggest
stage you know he would score in World
Cup finals he'd never go missing on
those big big occasions
um and I think he just came along at the
right time the sport needed someone like
that and he was the first to come along
and be this Superstar so I think often
we'll have the debate about who's the
greatest
um and it's something in our film we
never really wanted to get into there's
some cross-generational debates
um I think one thing would always say is
that Pele is the comparison point you
know first it was your Savio then kreif
then Maradona
um then Messi and Ronaldo but they're
always being compared to Pele and I
think the one thing we can always say
whether he's the greatest or not that's
for other people to decide but he was
the first he was Elvis He was Neil
Armstrong he would no one can follow it
in his footsteps if it's possible to
even articulate such a thing in 20
seconds what's his legacy
I think his legacy more than anything is
what he did for his country before 1958
Brazil wasn't the wasn't the country of
football after 1970 it became the
country of football and we all know
Brazil today as this country football
and that's largely down to one man L.A
well said uh documentary director David
Trion many many thanks
thank you with me now is Mike Meadows
from DW Sports so Mark I have to say
when I was growing up there was one
indisputable greatest player ever and
his name was Pele what impact did he
have on the sport
well he changed it completely I mean he
is the only man to win the World Cup
three times and I think in the men's
game that record will stay I mean I've
just been in Qatar for the World Cup and
you saw with France how difficult it was
to retain the trophy they felt the final
hurdle to Argentina but pele's Brazil
side was the last team to do it in 1958
and 1962 and for him to kind of
transcend three different decades in
International Football is quite
incredible I mean precautious talent in
1958 then established star in 62 and
then to come back in 1970 with probably
the best World Cup team we've ever seen
in the Brazil side in 1970 and win again
is quite incredible but of course it was
a lot more than just a footballer he was
a sports minister in Brazil as well and
if we're talking about sport in general
he's up there with Muhammad Ali Serena
Williams Usain Bolt the true sporting
greats and of course he was also a black
guy corn I mean we have to think back to
the 1950s and racism was a problem in
Brazil between richer white Brazilians
and black Brazilians and mixed race
Brazilians and he sort of helped bridge
that Gap he made white Brazilians
realize that they could support a brat
Brazilian and that the Brazilian
football team was was everything to them
excellent point um
I imagine I know the answer to this
question but how is a football Universe
reacting to his death I mean it's quite
incredible I've never seen anything like
this every single top player has tweeted
or put an Instagram post up about Pele
he's that important just that four
letter word everybody knew Pele even
people in countries where football isn't
so popular they knew Pele I mean Neymar
who is is kind of the successor as
Brazil's top player he said before Pele
10 was just a number and that's a nod to
the position where Pele played you know
the number 10 is the great iconic
position in football the player has the
skill who has the guile and without Pele
we wouldn't have had Neymar we wouldn't
have had Maradona we wouldn't have had
Totti and we wouldn't have had a Lionel
Messi so that shows the impact he had on
the game now Messi of course has also
commented he just tweeted a photo of
them together and said rest in peace
while Cristiano Ronaldo are of a modern
great has called him the Eternal King we
only have a 15 seconds but Mark any
details for the preparations yeah I mean
the funeral will take place in Santos's
Hometown it will happen on Monday and
Tuesday his coffin will be placed on the
center circle so fans can come and see
it and then the casket will be taken on
Tuesday to a local Cemetery for burial
the king is dead at 82 Mark Meadows DW
Sports many thanks